hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Robot Unicorn Attack
heavy metal Edition yes back by popular
demand because apparently I've lost
control of my life so here we go yeah
press SE and prepare for
Agony
yeah oh
[Music]
yeah w
infinitely more awesome I mean as much
as I love
rainbows
no
no oh look at the graphics so incredible
these a just a God that one snuck up on
me flying
blood
it's
so so metal
man
no ah come on I was trying to dash there
one more try Final
Nightmare
oh what what have I devolved into what
kind of let's play or am I
now am I am I even taken seriously
anymore or is this too serious from any
ah come
[Music]
on un
oh I can't do
it I can't do
it all right one more try let's do it
again Chase your
[Music]
demise
so much mle [__] a come on [__] I
hit the
[Music]
buttons
oh uhoh uhoh there we
go nailed it nailed it nailed it nailed
it nailed it nailing
it
in oh
no
I I will admit I feel a bit more
comfortable playing this version than
the rainbow version nothing against
rainbows but come
on oh this one so [__]
[Music]
metal didn't think I was going to going
to make that
one so many
explosions all right there you have it
everybody
ons right let's
and we follow the
and don't you you hear me
crying
C
byebye